hey guys I'm just McDonald you are
watching gamespot news and it's now
februari 13th which means it's
officially too late to rustle up a date
for Valentine's Day not to worry though
we've got video games so we already
heard that metal gear solid ground
zeroes is set to look better on ps4 the
Creator who dey okajima's prayed for the
console didn't stop there Kadima has
come out to say that the ps4 is able to
render 1080p at 60fps with what he calls
room to spare Kadima said the image
quality of the ps4 is the most beautiful
and is the closest to the photorealistic
quality that the dev team are aiming for
kijima was careful to say that this was
in comparison to other hardware and
didn't call out the xbox one
specifically in his comments on the
power of the ps4 as with any other day
of the week resolution gate is raging
but today Microsoft have come out to
talk 1080p as well so this could get
interesting we reported the other day
about a suggestion from sniper elite
senior producer jean-baptiste falcata
that the Xbox ones embedded SRAM was too
small to output 1080p and Microsoft's
corporate VP Phil Harrison has said this
is not the case he points to the
examples of sorts of five and kinect
sports rivals which both run at 1080p to
be fair though as many of you in the
comments pointed out it was never
suggested by bocado that the xbox one
couldn't handle 1080p jazz the des may
have had to employ tricks and
workarounds to achieve it you guys think
the issues run deeper than this or are
these games a good example of how the
Xbox one is probably gonna pick up its
game now for a story that's not about
consoles all resolutions teams
introduced what may well be the biggest
trolling feature ever themed tagging
said steam tagging is in beta and
involves allowing users to add text tags
to games and software on this store
pages now in theory this is a great way
to browse attack the similar games or
help users get a feel to what a game
might entail well that certainly
happened what's happened alongside that
are things like Dark Souls getting a
casual tag and gone home getting tags
like walking simulator
and not a game trash has also become a
pretty popular addition to the tags on
an awful lot of games do you guys reckon
the feature will take off or will it be
destroyed by the trolls you can let me
know what you think in the comments down
below or on my Twitter where I'm at Jess
McDonald there's all the things that I
wanted to tell you about today but be
sure to join me again tomorrow where
I've got my top five favorite stories of
the whole week I'll see you then